The end of this string is at the point 40, 30, and the link to this string is
50 centimeter. Great work if you found these two answers. Now, for the end of
the string we just want to have a coordinate pair. The x distance is 40 units
or 40 centimeter, and the y, or vertical distance is 30, 30 centimeter. The
length of this string is actually the hypotenuse of this right triangle. So we
can use the Pythagorean theorem to solve for the length of the string. We'll
have a squared, which is 30, plus b squared, which is 40, equal to c squared,
our hypotenuse. When we square these two numbers we'll get 900 plus 1600. Then
when we sum these numbers we will get 2500 equal to c squared. Now we just want
to take the square root of both side of our equation to solve for c. Taking the
square root of both sides, will only keep the positive root, since we're
dealing with a distance, so c equals 50 centimeter. Now the much faster
approach, to solving this, would be to understand that we have a 3, 4, 5 right
triangle. The ratio has just been multiplied by 10. So, this side is 30, this
side is 40. And this length of our string, is 50 centimeters. If you solved it
using that 3, 4, 5 ratio, amazing work.